-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
announced yesterday
that he was suspending
his presidential campaign.
And this only a few days
after Iowa announced it.
[ Laughter ]
After DeSantis suspended
his presidential campaign
and endorsed
former President Trump,
Trump said that he will retire
the nickname
Ron DeSanctimonious.
Added Trump,
"If I kept using it,
that would be very unfair
to my good friend
Meatball Ron."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's campaign
released a new ad yesterday
blaming former President Trump
for overturning
Roe versus Wade,
prompting an immediate response
from the Trump campaign --
"Can we use this too?"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden last week
canceled
$5 billion
in student loan debt.
"Wow, it's my lucky day,"
said the NYU grad.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
President Biden canceled
$5 billion in student loan debt.
Or if you go to UMass,
whatever that is in
Marlboro Miles.
[ Laughter ]
Look, we have a writer from
Massachusetts who writes these.
We have an on-staff
"Masshole"...
[ Laughter ]
...named Mike Scollins,
whose respon--
We have -- Look,
we have a writer from Arizona.
We have one from Florida,
so a lot of that's inbound.
We have one of the heirs
to the Arby's fortune.
[ Laughter ]
We have a Spirit Airlines pilot.
A lot of the stuff we do...
[ Laughter ]
After presidential candidate
Nikki Haley
questioned his mental fitness,
former President Trump
defended his abilities
at a rally on Saturday
and said he recently
aced a cognitive test.
Said Trump, "I found
all the motorcycles."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
"And I did good too,
because
they gave me a second set.
[ Laughter ]
I made it to level two
of motorcycles.
[ Laughter ]
They were like, 'Whoa,
this is never hap--
You got all the motorcycles.'
Sometimes I wondered. It was
just part of a motorcycle."
In a recent sermon,
Pope Francis warned
that pornography brings
"satisfaction
without relationship."
That story again,
the Pope is bad at warnings.
[ Laughter ]
Your warning
against pornography
shouldn't sound like
the tagline for a porn site.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Kraft Singles
have announced
that they will launch
three new flavors
for the first time
in nearly 10 years,
and hopefully
one of them is cheese.
[ Laughter ]
Officials in an Italian province
recently announced
the new plan to use DNA
to track down
and find dog owners
who don't pick up
their pet's droppings.
And, this is cool,
it also helped them
finally catch the Zodiac Killer.
[ Laughter ]
Are you more bummed
'cause it's a dog?
[ Laughter ]
The sandwich chain Subway
has announced
that it will offer
footlong Auntie Anne's pretzels
and Cinnabon churros.
It's never a good sign
for your restaurant
when your best idea is "what if
we sold someone else's food?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
officials in New Jersey
recently discovered that a gas
station was selling a gas --
was selling gas -- excuse me --
that was nearly 60% water,
which is especially shocking
because in Jersey,
not even the water
is 60% water.
[ Laughter ]
We do not -- We do not have
any Jersey writers on staff.
That was -- The entire crew!
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.